how does a steamy sex scene turn into
one of the most intimate moments in all
of The Witcher franchise Henry Cavill
knows that Torrid and passionate love
affair between geralt of Rivia and
Jennifer of wengerberg is a central part
of Netflix's The Witcher season one The
Witcher and the all-powerful Mage share
more than just chemistry their romantic
connection grows over time and becomes
something perhaps more binding than
either of them can articulate it makes
sense because their relationship spans
years and is full of steamy nights
followed by mornings Full Of Heartache
in one powerful scene geralt decides to
bind his Fates to Universe through a
jinn's wish to save her however good his
intentions were it fractures Jennifer's
trust and the relationship along with it
that's why we can't escape each other
why I feel this way inside though they
part ways it doesn't mean girl's is
without companionship another Contender
for the witch's heart is sorceress Tris
Marigold This Love Triangle in The
Witcher is a source of great debates
that leads viewers to wonder which woman
if any is right for him although it
seems Gerald leans toward team yennefer
there are still moments for him to share
with both women in season two when it
comes to his connection to yennefer it
seems or may not be entirely lost in
season 2 the couple reunites and shares
a moment that speaks to their feelings
for one another as it turns out Henry
Cavill and Anya chalotra played an
integral role in getting the tone of
this scene right the reunion between
Jennifer and Gerald and The Witcher was
a long time coming at the beginning of
the Season geralt operated under the
assumption that yennefer died at the
Battle of sudden Hill and even after her
heartbreak in season 1 Jennifer still
desires geralt their reunion is
important for the couple and while
filming season two it was even more
important for the actors to get it right
Henry Cavill stated that what was
originally on the script page was not
what's he and co-star Anya chalotra
filmed in an interview with sci-fi wire
Cavill said we just wanted to be very
careful that it was true and real and it
didn't turn into something that we as
actors didn't believe it should be when
Jennifer and geralt unite they kiss but
it doesn't go further than that Cavill
continued he wanted it to be emotional
rather than sexual it was really really
important and we had to lean away from
what was originally on the page
initially geralt and Jennifer were
written to have a more passionate Knight
but kaval and chalotra did not think
that would stay true to the characters
this was a moment about emotional
connection a sexual liaison would have
been distracting and something that
didn't stand the right message about how
those characters felt at that moment
Henry Cavill and Anya chalotria went to
The Witcher producers and explain why
they thought a steamy evening was not
the way to go caval explained that
geralt at this point thought yennefer
was dead he said these are people who
believe one thing about the fate of
another and then find out something else
is true that's not how they behave how
they behave is they just want to be with
the person and emotionally recognize her
existence again in that shared space so
Anya and I work to make sure that that
was an emotional beat rather than
anything else love and blood
they both possess a mighty power
another aspect of Gary Walton Jennifer's
relationship involves Siri in the books
Jennifer was like a mother to the
princess the new scene shows geralt
Jennifer and Siri getting to know one
another it's essential groundwork for
the Newfound family to bond kaval and
chalotra's active involvement to be
working the scene ultimately served the
narrative by helping Siri integrate more
naturally into the group